el pasado mes de noviembre
Edición unilateral alemania desnton
dijo el presidente
cinossinpinandato visitaré Rusia y
Napoleón
y el último de los controles deslizantes del mundo si está en
visita deja impin asilo
Lulla Da Silva los otros intermediarios
salario oficial Arabia Saudita Irán si
Glianone en China el recto mal en
informe diplomático analiza la
porchettina está bajando trambushka
en el ámbito Internacional tuvimos con
Lorenzo Maggiorelli médico en la agencia
política el profesor vendrá al final
mes pontificio internacional
Universidad de Colombia Buenos días.
Lorenzo, bienvenido a este estudio.
francia24
este caso quien los presentará a quien
El maestro está interesado en el tipo de ropa.
cecina que necesita
il masaggina Y bueno, no son números.
las cosas son una ambascosa si estamos
viviendo en una época de
lágrimas de verano en el nido si lo es
poniendo puerro vendido tanto spaises
el poder del planeta
y stambuscando Alternativa si obviamente
el país de los brics son los espacios que
representa esta alternativa a para il
futuro y puede ser nombrado presidente de
Brasil Lula Y es y es en cambio en esto
momento Y si esta cuestionando
Roald estuvo sólido como defensor
de estabilidad y orden
global si se cuestiona la
rollo de dólar como moneda
internacional hablo mucho si
alejándose así de la caza
solución política alternativa sal y
Armonía suní del verano en Austria
El dólar ahora es su propio presidente.
Lula que se tocó la nuez con eso
porchese debe usar el dolar de
tipo de cambio internacional
en un banco que con razón tiene que desaparecer
implementar fue la solución
alternativa si Obviamente
Era sólido, no insípido. Sí, lo era.
Sonnino va a buscar algunas armas.
Defensor negro el rollo del dólar
ahora es una de las prioridades de la
dictado por el logo verde estado en Nidos
Iele lo que el tiene abiertamente
desafiando el rollo del dólar y
Sorrento es una idea nueva pero genial.
ciertamente parece preocupante
gobierno de biden
Sí. Es sólo uno de una serie de varios.
Antecedentes que sostienen la política.
exterior del estado en Unidos y en este
momento de la estadía mencionada aunque en
Entra Medio Oriente y Serbia
Arabia Saudita a Irán y luego
con razón se facilita porcino I
Soy, soy presidente contesimentosim.
visto al menos al final de la guerra
gratis siempre se transmite en
política exterior de
América Latina
que desaparece pero lo tomo depende de mi
de un gran impulso y algo de Cecina
era caro
autonomía en las políticas exteriores
enzuolitica comercial y obviamente
centroamericana que recientemente es
analizado en China rompiendo la relación
diplomático con Taiwán e
Sé que hay una posibilidad otra vez
aumentar su volumen
de Comercio
y obviamente no tengo una visión
Potenciales del desierto y ¿quién quiere un
sabor el estado asumió global aunque
al menos mantén la esperanza de que
tuvo grandes volúmenes de comercio
China San Remo
cambian de traves de en Proietto della
La iniciativa de Franca y luego la ruta de
proporción
Se han producido muchos grandes reveses
Guardas antiproyectiles en el interior de infraestructuras.
nuestro continente África pide
Europa por la visita de los deslizadores
Versión europea contra la pared que Europa
pide calmarse un poco, depende
pero tan vigilia se encontraron
El cambio climático no muestra quién sabe.
de Europa la que se ve y la última
visita a las noticias de Emmanuel Macron en
fondarlain que tenemos un consenso sobre el
Como tra tarzantina en oferta en un
Error de Macron
Sí, no hay consenso en Europa sobre
regular debe ser la posición opuesta
China y no se sabe ahora que comentó y
Estoy buscando uno de China.
propiedad de la póliza de Even the
Merkel y vía Sidoli y el ocultismo
discusión láser con China la ventana con
Rusia y la idea de comunidad de destino
compartimento y en el continente del euro
Asiático Proviene de la política de
Incluso a Merkel y a usted les gustaría esta idea.
de la guerra en Ucrania Sí, si el país
Los europeos ocuparon un lugar destacado
sonito conectado condenando el
Sin embargo, la invasión rusa de Ucrania
no el mes pasado si tiene videos
presidente que Sean distanció a Macron
porce Quest Francia Ali un poco de lobrix
el esta buscando un puesto
independiente para los sunitas interesados
Francia pregunta si era una potencia
global hablo mucho no preguntes
alinearse automáticamente con el
estado posición estados unidos oteros país
enano diferente sinterespolonia y
en reversa
si el país que la masculinidad
realinearse con estaba unido si yo
no solo sablaron
y es alianza estratégica con fue
Realmente jugué muchos años de Cadapaisti.
una posición diferente, sí, es una
tradición la política exterior de
de la Unión Europea, pero también realmente
El francinismo o la Unión Europea
muy cerca de china
o si la independencia se ha convertido en potencia
para el campeonato mundial
[Música]
la energía nuclear europea y Francia e
Hablo mucho y lo crearé.
de la nación unida y sostenida
el potencial para ser grande
poder en Jesolo de un lado entonces es
Serbia parece que Europa mantiene una
posición independiente de estatus unido
pero tengo que trolearlo y si si viene
baccandole verano sunita armonía y
sabes cómo ser un gran Fuente Den
estabilidad Parra política global
lorenzo
estudio de Francia 24